Malik starting the tournament can always
be rusty but starting tournament against
the top seed is never an easy task yet
you just won against the top seat right
in mirakovi and your initial feelings
after this important Victory Ikea was
happy to face him in the first round I
know a lot to be like for I counted for
45 years yeah we we grew up in the same
city so we knew each other like since
being a kids
we play many many games against each
other
yeah so yeah but it was very important
for me to play and I was hoping to get
white color and I got it you know how
did you prepare for this game well
firstly it was sort of expected from
other mid to play Sicilian I thought he
wouldn't play against me like E4 E5
because I thought he's like you know
hire the player and he wouldn't play
like like symmetrical or Lopez or
something like that so it was expecting
but I actually mainly prepared against
the other lines so for me a line which
Vladimir played
um I saw the game against he played
against another Beck um back to 2015. so
I thought it's only one single game and
it's not really principal Queen C7
because I thought it's supposed to be
Bishop before right but he didn't play
Bishop before and he never published
before by the way he only played Queen
C7 so okay I thought the setup which I
played is quite known
up to rookie 8. it felt like he just
wanted to get a longer game and try to
get you maybe in time travel and then
yeah make a push for something but I
mean I'm familiar with the system
because I I same system I teach all my
students and we talk about this actually
in our Olympian experience so I knew up
to like uh rookie yet moment yeah it was
so a first surprise when um he played
rookie eight
yeah because funny like um I thought the
the right was supposed to be like Bishop
d a bishop C7 right so this is like a
very common idea yeah Bishop da Bishop
C7 because um I'm actually not making on
time uh typical King H1 move
and why is that well I mean he played
Bishop C7
yes and let's say you go Bishop G1 right
that's what I thought Bishop G1 and
actually that's what uh something like
this happened with no not big another
big plate so he goes D5 or what is the
problem well actually I was thinking to
I was considered between this line or to
play as I was thinking like initially
Bishop F1 Bishop uh if you don't play
King H1 second yes uh play uh Bishop F1
and then something like this and then I
thought it's not a big deal I can play
uh let's say G3 or something like that
yeah okay and it was scenario I can play
j3 and then you know its position I mean
I kind of play this in some Blitz Games
uh something like that so I thought it's
fine but uh either this or King H1 but I
thought let him think and then let's see
what he does he actually spent some time
on 95 right E8 yes
he gave me like very valuable time so
now I can play Bishop F1 uh not E5 yeah
also I I didn't I didn't actually
expected this I thought he's going to
play something like Bishop f8
but I mean I wasn't sure like what's the
point yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know it's Sicilian like cam
positions typical plants yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah but he played that E5 A4 here
yeah by the way I missed something right
here I missed something right this is
the critical moment go back for a second
yes yeah I knew there's something wrong
with this and I knew I supposed I mean I
supposed to take Knight B6
going to xp6 Knight F5 okay yeah and the
five Queen whatever goes I don't care
yeah seven take on D6
but I simply check it out okay because
same sacrifice we have uh in Sicilian in
idorph uh whenever you suck on B5 and it
was kind of similar thing when you cycle
for three points three pawns no it's
only two
you might be getting the third one yes I
was trying to compare remember the
famous game when the way he was very
young and he played against shirov I
think and won the World Cups are testing
my memory my own live TV yes sir do you
remember that oh absolutely
yeah I mean it's kind of sacrifice but
honestly I saw this but actually you
know I mean I got
I thought maybe I'm gonna miss something
and this and that uh
yeah I'm going to blame myself with this
and then I played that between but it's
still big enough but I misjudged the
position I thought this is supposed to
be good for me yes number five initially
I was speaking Bishop G3 and that's why
I went for this exchange accepted
exchange sacrifice I thought Bishop G3
and I'm clearly better but then I
realized after d is not so better you
know
but apparently uh computer says here not
E3 which is yeah very difficulties yeah
yeah very very difficult yeah I didn't
see it because my I mean I spent some
time by uh trying to evaluate green B2
move not Queen G5 yeah uh but then I
realized on computer he has a bishop C
flat check something like that it's like
annoying yeah yeah right you play the
bishop to G5 this was a moment where he
had an option but I really like this
move Queen to H3 I showed instantly yes
yeah put a lot of pressure on him on his
next tactical position uh Christian I
had to do something I can't handle this
position only because uh one one move
late uh he's going to be two Bishops
he's gonna kill me yeah yeah so I gotta
do something actually I believe A5 is a
big mistake
we agreed to we spoke briefly with
Vladimir
um it was expected which I thought G6
move and I was thinking to make a check
and another six uh capture capture
Bishop before and I said whatever you
know what let's see let's play this
position like whatever it is 23 back and
uh I mean I think it's roughly equal
right sure yeah Dynamic dynamically yes
yeah I mean he definitely had the
conversation uh but I mean uh when he
played A5 I was very happy uh I said
okay I saw Queen Street because I saw
this even before K5 I thought I was
hoping if you play A5 because I saw
Queen stream because funny but Rook is
trapped there is no there is no good
Square for The Rook yeah yeah yeah and
everything just keep contact exactly
yeah yeah there's always there should be
several I mean Bishop D7 I thought uh
but no matter what any animal was better
than Queen E6 yeah I think this one is
just losing yes and you spotted it
directly the exchange of the Queens
definitely helps you after 28 yeah yeah
this is what that that win yeah maybe
most precise was not a captain and play
this was like Rook D7 initially but I
said whatever it doesn't matter as long
as it gets the result yeah yeah that you
want it congratulations great thank you
Chris thank you to start the game uh to
start a tournament with guys back to you